hey 42 here humans have always been
Enchanted by gold we done it devour it
drink it serenade it even defecate to
top it and when the chips are down we
kill for it from King Midas to the
California Gold Rush when it comes to
this most precious of precious metals we
simply lose our tiny little Minds given
this centuries-old Love of All Things a
you it's no wonder that gold has
remained a target of the criminally
inclined and there is no Heist bigger
than that of the brink mats bullion raid
in which an armed gang bursts into a
warehouse near Heathrow Airport and made
off with 26 million pounds worth of pure
gold
The Heist hailed as the crime of the
century was at the time the largest in
British history but the theft itself was
merely the start of the story because
after stealing three tons of solid gold
these newly minted millionaires had to
figure out just what the hell they were
going to do with it
surf shark VPN keeps you safe and
private by covering up everything you do
online and surfsharkvpn lets you travel
the world virtually by changing your
virtual location so you can view
websites and content that might not be
available in your country or if you are
physically traveling surfshark lets you
connect via your home country so you
don't miss out on your home Comforts
such as streaming video content from
home that might be blocked whilst you're
traveling there are over 3 200 servers
in a hundred countries so anywhere
you'll go you'll find a server that fits
your needs and personally I love surf
shark's IP Rotator feature which
constantly changes your device's IP
address without losing your VPN
connection it's really important to stay
safe online when you're out and about
and that's where I use surfsharkvpn so I
can for example access my online banking
safely even on public Wi-Fi there's no
chance I do that without a VPN vpns also
keep your location and download history
private so you can send and receive file
securely which is really important when
working with sensitive business data
quite simply surfsharkvpn is an
essential tool and by using the Code 42
you'll benefit from an 83 discount plus
free extra mums for free all you have to
do is click the special link in the
description below don't miss out and
thanks to surfshark for sponsoring this
video
the Brinks Matt rage took place at 6 30
a.m on the 26th of November
1983. say what you like about armed
robbers but they do get to work early
the gang was led by two career criminals
Brian the colonel Robinson and mad
Mickey mikavoy one of whom was said to
be the brains of the operation and the
other a certified hard ass I'll leave
you to work out which was which there
was also an inside man security guard
Anthony black he was married to Brian
Robinson's sister and he happily spilled
his gut to his criminal in-law about the
large sums of money that were held at
the brinksmat warehouse where he worked
as far as highs go this one was absurdly
simple during his rounds black casually
unlocked a side door granting access to
the seemingly secure warehouse for the
rest of his crew then six balaclava clad
Bandits burst in quickly subduing their
security guards who far from ready to
defend the game the incursion we're
enjoying a nice hot cup of tea and the
gossip next on the to-do list was
gaining access to the vault only select
guards knew the codes and black wasn't
one of them so the gang politely asked
one of the ones who did if he wouldn't
mind handing them over when that didn't
work they tried the more direct route of
putting a knife to his throat pouring
petrol over his privates and
suggestively lighting a match but before
the poor man had a chance to Cuff up the
codes one of the crew spotted something
strange
sitting right in the middle of the
warehouse were several large boxes each
concealing
6800 solid gold ingots the Brinks mad
robbers had hoped to steal around 1
million pounds worth of foreign currency
From the Vault instead they found 26
times that just sitting there it was the
highest equivalent of winning the
lottery except when people win the
lottery they aren't usually holding a
shotgun and threatening to burn
someone's [__] off also when you win the
lottery you get one of those really big
novelty checks which must be an absolute
nightmare to pay into the bank but a
damn sight easier than transporting
three tons of gold the crew had
anticipated a swift Smash and grab
operation what they hadn't planned on is
that almost two hours later they'd still
be loading the loot into the van with a
forklift truck
so laid him with loot was the getaway
vehicle that they struggled to get away
at all leaving the scene at a pace
surpassed by my gran on a midnight trip
to the toilet they did manage to escape
before the alarm was raised but soon
enough the chase was afoot the London
Police Department dedicated to organized
crime is known as the flying Squad
better known by its Cockney rhyming
slang The Sweeney Sweeney Todd flying
Squad they had a reputation for being
every bit as tough as the crims they
pursued so it wasn't long before they
started putting those gold bar Bandits
Behind Bars of a different variety
Anthony black the Inside Man was the
first to be brought in as soon as the
cops realized he was a brother-in-law of
a known Criminal
didn't really think that one through did
he black folded under questioning and
confessed to his part in the crime he
also coughed up the names of the Ring
leaders Brian Robinson and Mickey McAvoy
who were both arrested only 10 days
after the raid not that Eva had been
lying low in the interim both
immediately swapped their humble family
homes for significantly swankier
properties purchased in cash and just in
case any doubt remained McAvoy further
confirmed his culpability by trying to
punch Anthony black in the face during a
police lineup
a year later Robinson and McEvoy were
sentenced to 25 years each with black
getting six years unlike black mkavoy
and Robinson remains silent they never
gave up their accomplices and the other
four men involved still haven't been
caught to this day
with the ring leaders safely in prison
you might think it would have been easy
to track the stolen loot after all how
the hell do you even begin to launder
three tons of a very shiny metal step
forward John Palmer the man the Press
would later Christen the real-life
Goldfinger and with a very good reason
despite growing up in extreme poverty in
Birmingham Palmer had a knack for making
money he left school at a young age and
started selling scrap metal and
second-hand cars before moving into
jewelry and gold by the time of the
Brinks met robbery in 1983 Palmer was
living in a Georgian Mansion near the
historic town of bath where he had his
own smelter a mini furnace for melting
metal as a well-known Criminal Who owned
a gold melting machine he was the
perfect person to liquidate the gang's
assets literally just two days after the
robbery Palmer's affluent neighbors
alerted the police about his frantic
backyard smelting
unsurprisingly they figured it might
have something to do with that free tons
of stolen gold making news headlines the
police turned off but for reasons that
have been lost to history they decided
not to take things any further that left
Palmer free to melt down huge quantities
of gold which he mixed with copper to
disguise his Origins he then sold it
onto unsuspecting companies including
one called Johnson Mafi the very same
company that owned the gold in the first
place I mean stealing someone's gold is
one thing but selling it back to them at
an inflated price after you've decreased
the quality that's just criminal in
total 13 million pounds worth of gold
profit went through the accounts of
Palmer's personal company which he
wasn't at all shy about spending however
ineffective the police might have been
previously they eventually began to
suspect Palmer's involvement and raided
his mansion in 1985. the chocolate was
by that point it was too late he'd taken
his family to Tenerife for a short
holiday that ended up lasting two years
funny that he did eventually return to
blighty in 1987 and was promptly put on
trial for his part in disposing of the
gold but it seemed he'd spent the
intervening years polishing up his case
because despite admitting to Melting and
selling the gold he was cleared of all
charges his defense was simple he
claimed he never knew the gold was
stolen
might sound hard to believe but
apparently the jury saw things
differently Palmer left the courtroom
that day blowing them kisses before
hopping on a plane straight back to
Tenerife where he'd set up a dodgy
timeshare business at this point Palmer
wasn't the only one of the extended
criminal family connected to the Brink's
mad robbery that the police were
pursuing they were also after lifelong
gangster Kenneth Noy an expert fence who
had a reputation for being able to shift
all kinds of ill-gossing gains
like Palmer annoy was thought to have
played a pivotal part in melting down
the brink smack gold and laundering the
money which its sales brought in as a
prime suspect noise was placed under
close police surveillance which is how
one night an undercover officer came to
be hiding camouflaged in his back Garden
apparently no he was a proud
horticulturist because on finding the
police officer camped out in his
chrysanthemums he stabbed him to death
at the subsequent Trail Noy pulled off
an even more unlikely Victory than John
Palmer claiming he'd stabbed the police
officer 10 times in the chest in
self-defense
he was found not guilty thankfully Noy
face caught again less than a year later
when police found 11 solid gold bars in
his house
even knee apparently easily LED jurors
of 1980s England couldn't ignore that
glaring evidence
was fined 500 000 pounds and given 15
years in prison he was released in 1994
but two years later he murdered someone
else it seems old habits quite literally
died hard this time he killed a motorist
at a road rage incident and then fled
the country the following day and went
on the run for four years
you may be wondering how a convicted
criminal wanted for murder managed to
slip away so easily well I assume he
donned one of those pairs of glasses
with a false nose and mustache attached
but sadly no like Ringo Starr from the
Beatles Noy Had a Little Help from his
friends only with less drumming and more
stabbing
in this case noise friend was none other
than old Goldfinger himself John Palmer
perhaps there's honor Amongst Thieves
after all Palmer had not flown out of
the UK in his private helicopter which
took him to Palmer's private golf course
in France from there Noy took Palmer's
leojet to Tenerife where authorities
lost track of him altogether Neuer is
believed to have orchestrated at least
three mob murders whilst On The Run
either to evade law enforcement or to
avenge those he believed have wronged
him he was eventually arrested in Spain
and extradited back to the UK where he
was sentenced to life in prison but hang
on a second did I just say that John
Palmer owned a helicopter and a golf
course and the Learjet yes yes I did
because whilst Kenny Noy had spent years
locked up Palmer has spent that time
cleaning up making an absolute fortune
in a scam of huge proportions you see
his holiday apartment timeshare business
was nothing but a huge con it grew to be
an empire in playing hundreds of people
and made Palmer a personal Fortune of
over 300 million pounds meaning that at
one point he was almost as rich as the
actual Queen of England
Palmer's vast wealth was all built on
lies and up to 20 000 customers were
tricked into paying for apartments that
didn't exist
if they refuse to pay Palmer's hired Fox
convinced them to change their minds not
only that but Palmer was caught on
camera by legendary British
investigative journalist Roger cook
offering to launder 60 million pounds
worth of drug money and boasting about
how he could get guns from the Russian
mafia Justice though long overdue
eventually caught up with Palmer who
like noi was extradited back to the UK
he was put on trial found guilty and
sentenced to eight years for fraud he
was released after four years to
continue his life of crime until 2015
when he was shot dead outside his
mansion in the English Countryside no
one has been convicted of his murder the
brutal end to Palmer's life is typical
of many of those associated with the
Brinks map Heist which superstitious
types have suggested may be cursed in
total 20 people involved in the heist
have been murdered over the years many
others have languished in prison
original robbers Robinson and Mickey
you've got long sentences and both died
penniless their shares of the stash
having evaporated by the time they were
released as for the gold itself the vast
majority was never recovered and its
whereabouts Remain the subject of
fevered speculation even today so much
stolen gold was processed by the thieves
that according to some estimates almost
everyone who bought gold jewelry in the
UK after 1984 is wearing at least some
Brinks Mac Gold other Tales claim the
laundered money has been invested in
everything from International drug
trafficking to the large-scale
Redevelopment of the docklands area in
London with so many having taken their
secrets to early Graves it seems likely
we'll never know the whole truth and the
Mystery of the Brinks Matt robbery like
the goals that was taken that day will
continue to Fascinate and tantalize us
for years to come thanks for watching